here is a clip of noted racist Joy Reid
on the televised mental institution
known as MSNBC calling Elon Musk and Ron
DeSantis fascists and authoritarians
what doing it all over again but for
Elon this time
this is the person DeSantis most
identifies with these days they share an
ideology that seems libertarian on the
surface meaning certain people basically
people who look like Elon Musk and Ron
DeSantis get the freedom to do or say
whatever I want whatever I want no
matter how racist cruel or offensive no
censorship no masks my body my choice
but for you it's pure authoritarianism
wokism is dangerous fascism though free
speech don't tread on me is for them
the authoritarianism is for you
your kid can't read certain books or
learn about history while their kids get
Christian prayer in school and get to
hurl the n-word on Twitter with no
consequences they get to decide what
bathroom you use what you can wear they
even get to tell you your gender
identity and your kids too that's not up
to you that's their call oh and ladies
your body their choice
musk has become a guru for people who
share this philosophy libertarianism for
me my rules for thee
DeSantis wants to take that Mo all the
way to the White House capping off his
launch with an anti-woke rant on Fox
News
the woke mind virus is basically a form
of cultural Marxism at the end of the
day it's an attack on the truth and
because it's a war on truth I think we
have no choice but to wage a war on woke
my virus he says you know a nonsense
term created by you guessed it Elon Musk
what does that even mean for most
Americans
we're just a bunch of zombies infected
not by covet no no surely that virus is
fake while the real virus according to D
and dumb is wokeism and the Cure having
the government of Florida and if
DeSantis gets his way the federal
government tell us how to dress where to
pee but especially what to read she's
really just a terrible person like I
don't know how you analyze this with
like more thought put into it than that
she's a liar and she's actually a racist
and all that stuff Elon Musk for his
entire life he was pretty I actually
mentioned this to him in the meeting
that we had I said something about how
you were a lefty most of your life and
he responds he's like you know that's
what everyone thinks he was like he's
like actually I was just kind of
apolitical my entire life but by default
factory setting default he was voting
for Democrats his entire life so he's
certainly he's not a fascist or an
authoritarian or anything else and if
you're paying attention to what he's
done on Twitter all he's done is take
away censorship there you know how many
people say horrible things about him all
day horrible things about me horrible
things about DeSantis yeah okay fine it
is what it is you can block them or you
don't even have to open the app it's
really wild
[Music]